>> In the last few
years, actually,
I've been slowly
getting obsessed with
this particular topic
of Smart Cities.
It was just accidental
that I started into this,
but I think it's turning out
to be a very interesting,
I think rich space for
a lot of interesting
research problems,
which is what we are
interested in, but also,
an opportunity to really shape
how these things will get
implemented in India right now.
So, I'll just try to present
coherent story on
what we could do as
Technologists for enabling
really futuristic Smart Cities
solutions in India.
So, really one of
the main things which we
have been trying to make a case
for is like an open stack,
which will really
allow for a rich set
of applications to develop
and emerge in the future.
So, to motivate this,
what I'll do is I'll go a little
bit in detail into
this recent RFP,
which has been put out
by the City of Agra,
which I'm sure Betel Nolkia
would be able to tell you
in much greater detail of
many of the other
aspects of this RFP.
We'll just focus on
the technology related aspects
of this particular RFP.
I presume that this is
a prototypical RFP
for a Smart City,
which is similar to a
lot of what other cities
are doing or want to be done.
If you see out here,
one of the key elements
out here is this integrated
control and command center.
So, clearly they want
a visibility as to
the overall operations
of the city.
There are a number of
components which can plug
into this command
and Control Center.
Transportation,
intelligent traffic
management system,
solid waste management,
surveillance, interactions
with the citizens of the city,
being able to communicate through
digital signages, and so on.
So, these are all the
various components,
which they would like to have
executed in the RFP,
which they have given up.
So, what we thought was
let us go into this RFP
a little bit more detail
to understand
from a technology perspective.
What are the key elements
which will need to be supported?
So, the RFP also says
that you need to have
a layered approach and
this is common sense.
In some sense, especially with
all the sensors being
deployed like cameras etc.,
they advocate having
these multiple layers
out here, sensor layer,
communication layer, data
layer and application layer.
What I would like to focus on,
as we go forward in this talk
is essentially this layer,
the data layer,
which I believe is like
the core fundamental layer which
we really need to make sure
it's designed and
constructed well
because it will really enable
all kinds of interesting
things to happen in the top,
once if that is done well.
So, if you look at
this adaptive
traffic management system,
what they would really
like to do is to be able
to manage the traffic in a
reactive, in a smart way.
For example, they
want to be able to
control the traffic
signals optimally,
so that it can change as
required based on the duration,
on the time of the day, and
the traffic conditions.
I guess this is
a big deal in India, we
are happy the way it goes.
So, they want to be able to
automatically create these
corridors for VIP vehicles,
as well as emergency,
and police vehicles.
They would like to actually have
incident messaging being
done in real time.
Also, there are little
forward-looking in the
sense that they're
saying let us collect this data
of all the traffic conditions,
make it available, so that
it can be used for
further analysis,
and improvement of
the road networks.
So, if we look at the
implication on the data layer,
this real timeness is
important which emerges
when you want to
quickly be able to connect
to various things.
Also, you want to be
able to, of course,
it's not immediately
apparent from here,
but if you look at
the RFP detail,
it's also apparent that
you want to be able to
ingest data from
a diversity of sources,
cameras, crowdsource, police
database systems, etc.
Similarly, you want to
make the data available to
a diversity of applications,
and it's not just this adaptive
traffic management
system application,
but maybe other applications.
They have this,
yeah?
>> [inaudible].
>> That is a very good point
and I don't have
an answer to that.
I mean, if you don't have
enough capacity of the road,
I mean there's not much you
can do in terms of that.
But, hopefully, you can at
least do some demand
response type thing.
You can stagger how
people- titles cannot even
know the capacity by,
it's creating incentive
schemes, and so on.
>> You don't study [inaudible].
Because you are not. You
are already spending
money on something
that is zero result.
>> So, that is one view
is that why do all
these when we can't even
make a proper footpath.
Were not even able to walk
properly and we want to fly.
But, maybe we cannot
bypass this like what
we did with wireless,
it directly gone to smartphone by
passing the intermediate layers.
So, the other thing is that,
I think one of
the things also which is
embedded in the RFP turns out,
is that just making the
information available
hopefully will allow citizens
to say look what the heck
are you doing.
Are you doing your job?
Why aren't you fix
this and so on.
So, that also hopefully
there'll be some positive
comes sort of just making
the data available.
>> [inaudible]
>> Right. Yes. Agra, I
don't think- as it's
said everything-
>> Bike.
>> Bicycles, okay. So, you
have to also get
the appropriating challenge.
>> [inaudible]
>> There are a lot of
interesting, okay.
So, I'll point out
something funny out here.
So, intelligent
traffic NCC turbulent.
So, traffic comes again
in two different places,
adapter traffic as well
as as part of this,
but I'm just reporting
what they set out there.
Here, they really want to
have the system to
support the police.
So, this from the point of view
of the police's perspective,
they want to be able
to traffic police,
be able to give finds,
do traffic management,
monitor suspicious people,
vital places, video analytics.
They want to be able to detect
no helmet whether someone
smoking in the car,
this is funny wrongly
driving detection.
So, they want that.
I don't know why.
They would like to actually also
detective people have
long hair or short hair.
It's there, this RFP.
So, this is interesting.
They would like to have a video
coming from ad-hoc video,
so similar you just set
up a video network,
and then data should
come from there,
or variable like police is
wearing a video camera,
data should be coming
from there, and so on.
Then, of course,
they want this to
empower secure communications.
So, what this implies
is for the data layer,
you need to support
end-to-end security,
and also diversity
of radio sources,
mobile, wearable,
ad-hoc type sources.
You need to really support
the diversity of analytics,
which might not be
doable right now,
and see their point is some
of these longer, shorter,
it might take time,
they want that,
but in the future,
you'll have more
requirements for analytics,
and then of course
strong authorization
and authentication.
Solid waste management, they
have this probably for
most of the cities.
They don't know what is going on,
where people actually
collecting the waste.
It's supposed to either
disposing of properly and so on.
So, you just need
more visibility by putting
sensors to track vehicles,
monitor waste collection sites,
manage the roots of
this trucks, etc.,
look at the handover from
one small truck to
the bigger truck,
what is going on,
things like that,
and really increase automation.
Again, out here diversity data
ingestion from
a diversity of sources
followed by video analytics.
They also want video analytics.
They want to see
what is happening in
the monitoring waste
disposal sites,
are things being done
properly or not.
They would like all of
this to be reported,
summary to be reported to
the integrated command
and Control Center.
GIS is a big deal for this,
I guess most of
the smart city RFPs,
where they would like to use this
for better revenue
management, and planning,
and urban development, and
maintenance of
public places, and so on.
They would like this
to get integrated with
other smart solutions
like in surveillance.
So, GIS is a important
requirement for the data layer,
being able to provide GIS data,
and space data, I'll
come to this what I
mean by this little
later in the talk.
So, that you can do a correlation
analysis of data from
all these different sensors
in the context of GIS data.
Air quality, noise, light,
and being able to report that
through messaging displays is
something they would like,
and they would also want
these to be tamper-proof.
So, this is where it's
interesting some of
the requirements are
coming up in
the specific components,
but they are genderly
or they cannot cut
across the entire
implementation of smart cities.
So, secure onboarding of
devices is important,
so that you can trust
the device which is
sending the data,
and detect if the
trust is broken.
You would like to know how
healthy these devices
are and then really,
again, coming back to
this exchanging data
between sensors and
other applications.
>> [inaudible]?
>> I guess, they want
to measure the amount
of noise decibel levels
in these places,
just monitor that, I guess.
I guess, if you had these
microphones you could also do
some analytics with that in
conjunction with the video,
though they're not asking for it,
but you could do
some interesting things
with that I guess.
>> [inaudible]?
>> Yeah. I don't know. I'm sure
there are certain positive
laws, I don't know.
I don't know actually. See, it's
like the air quality, right?
I mean, there are
certain safe air
quality levels to be maintained,
but we're kind of not
really maintaining that,
so probably, the same
happens with these lines.
>> [inaudible].
>> Taj? Okay. I see.
Yeah. So, Taj Mahal,
so that is driving some
of these requirements.
I guess, once you start having
data, see that is the thing,
is that maybe you can kind of use
that to drive some actions,
policy actions after
that, around that.
So, for example, this kind
of data would also be
useful to correlate
with the health implications
of the people living
in those areas.
So, we don't have data but
once we start having
this kind of data,
those kind of studies can
also be done and then we
could inform the city,
could do the appropriate things
in terms of, yes.
>> [inaudible].
>> For noise?
>> Yes.
>> Noise, I don't
know, but I do know
that maybe the same people,
because air quality
related studies,
some of the doctors in some of
these hospitals are interested
and they're kind of
doing that kind of
study along with
some scientists in ISC.
So, I guess, noise
is kind of related,
so probably, they would
also be interested in that.
>> [inaudible].
>> So, Saint John's is
something which is-.
>> [inaudible] in New York City
[inaudible] there
is city code about what
is allowed for noise,
and anything that is above
10dB above [inaudible]
which was informally stated
as 55dB is prosecutable.
Then they have
very specific prosecutions
for different types
of the offense,
and it is in fact treated
like a health hazard.
>> Health hazard.
>> It is known to also
affect educational outcome.
So, kids who are studying near
say railway lines [inaudible] ,
so, many agencies which are
interested in managing noise.
>> The air quality, for example,
the study which the ISC
scientist, Professor Satish,
did along with some of
his colleagues from
hospital was to look at
the asthma levels of
children in a school
before and after
some change in
the traffic routing.
There was a noticeable change in
the asthma levels when of
course they changed some
traffic- the paths for some
of these heavy vehicles.
Over a six-month period,
the asthma level actually went up
and then it came down
when the old routing
was reestablished.
So, clearly, there is
a major connection note
that the health and
even educational outcomes
too much noise meant also
prevent children from
focusing and so on.
So, they want this latency of
15 milliseconds round trip,
which I think it might be kind of
aggressive with sudden jitter
specs and loss specs and
so on for the communication
network and authentication
of devices through
the certificates
and being able to look at the
health of all these things.
So, I think the message
here is that real time is
important where anyone can meet
these specs or not is
a different issue.
But I think that makes sense if
there is a ambulance coming
in you want to notify
it and change
the signals and so on.
>> [inaudible].
>> I think it's Pricewater House
an issue [inaudible].
Yeah, exactly.
So, it could also be that
certain big corporates also
help come with these specs.
So that their equipments
could meet these standards.
I don't know how
this works. But-.
>> [inaudible] I think it
just goes one panic part of
[inaudible] there's no quality of
service with no spec
on how good your expenses
have to be or how accurate-.
>> Absolutely. In fact,
that is the point I kind of
want to make is that if
you look at these RFPs,
in some sense, this
is at the level
at which specs are written.
It's already like
300-page document.
You know, this technical stuff.
Then from there, to derive
even more detailed specs,
that's where what I want to make
a cases is that we
really need to get down
to those details of
being able to properly
get to the next level
of technical
specifications of each of these-.
>> Tasks specification,
I mean at the end,
this is not the specific [inaudible]
what you get out of it. [inaudible].
>> Yeah.
Yeah. That's why I cannot
put this up so that
it comes out this is the kind of
spec which is there
right now in the RFPs,
is what they're asking for that.
>> [inaudible].
>> Sorry, yes.
>> What is the [inaudible].
>> See, they just spec that it
needs to be end-to-end latency,
round trip latency
is 15-millisecond.
Now, I presume it
is probably they had
this applications like
the signaling traffic
light control
creating a green corridor
when a VIP vehicle comes or
emergency vehicle comes.
So, maybe that is driving
this particular spec.
Yeah.
>> [inaudible] 15 milliseconds
to exactly what?
>> Fifteen milliseconds from
the time the sensor says,
"Look, I'm emergency
vehicle. I am here."
to going and changing
probably the traffic light
to set the current green
corridor up in that local space.
I'm kind of speculating
that is what is driving,
one possible example use case
for this kind of a spec.
So, from the sensor,
it goes to the
communication network.
It has to go through the app.
So, here they are not even
mentioning anything with the app,
because there is
a complete application stack
through which it
goes and comes back.
Everything has to be
within 15-millisecond,
and the jitter of two percent
of 7.5-millisecond,
that is jitter two percent of
the one-way latency, probably,
for video or something, I
don't know where that is
coming from and what is
the motivation for that.
>> [inaudible].
>> Yes. So this is the- yeah.
The integrated command and
control is like the key
piece of the smart cities,
and really they have aspiration
to break the silos
between departments.
They want a single
window visibility
of all that is going on in
the city and they want to have
this integrated
operations platform
which is like the core of that,
which will expose
data through API,
support distributed
deployment of workflow,
Stream Analytics,
correlate handle multiple data
stream, developer support,
vendor agnostic,
Software Development Kit CPIs,
security APIs, and they
want to have Analytics
for lightning detection
abundant objects, etc.
I'm kind of bringing these
things up because this kind of
how the RFPs are also
written in some sense.
These are the consultants who
come in and write these RFPs.
There are some elements which are
captured which are what
is the cities want,
plus there are certain
other additional things
which I put it here.
>> [inaudible].
>> See, this is what they have
written in one of those places.
So, what we want to actually- we
seized on this and we're
saying, "Let's make this.
Let's try to get this thing,
achieve this as OpenStack,
open API framework."
Now, this RFP which has been
put and in the normal course
of operations,
what will happen is
that there will be
one master system integrator
like Star Lite or
LNT or someone will pull
together all the different
vendors for surveillance,
waste management, etc.,
etc., and probably,
each of the vendor will have
their own complete stack from
sensors all the way
to the dashboarding.
Then some other will
integrate it into
the- there'll be
a single command and control
center where you have
all these little snippets
of videos running from these
different applications.
So, it really siloed
in some sense.
So, that's probably
what will happen.
There is really nothing more
specified in terms
of further levels of
specification in terms
of standardizing
the framework for exchanging
data so that you
can really exchange data
across different applications,
devices, and even
cities in some sense.
You want to go to that level.
So, also really, there is
no support for an economy
based on data that is kind of
the recurrent thing
in any of these.
Datas are recurrent things.
They have to figure out how
to make money off data.
So, there is really
no support for that.
So that is a little bit future
thinking we need to do.
There is no mention of privacy.
So, you now know that is one of
the most important things
right now but there is really
no mention of privacy in these.
So, what we really need
is kind of a platform
which standardizes APIs and
the data models so that it
helps application developers.
It should be targeted at
application developers instead of
just having end
complete applications.
Then, it should really support
AI type solutions
which are emerging and
really unleash the innovation and
entrepreneurship for
new applications to develop.
>> [inaudible].
>> These applications?
>> Yes.
>> Yeah. There are
a lot of I think
already Pune has
implemented something
and some of the cities
which are a little bit early
have implemented that.
So you can have vendors,
for example, which will provide
you a solutions for surveillance.
So, there's someone called
Videonetics will provide
you that complete with the
cameras and VMS and all that.
Parking, I guess a lot of
players startups and so on,
and so lighting management-.
>> [inaudible].
>> Pardon?
>> [inaudible]
>> Right.
>> [inaudible].
>> Radiolytics, yes.
>> Is there any law in India
that protects privacy?
>> I think there is
something which is there in
this the Data Empowerment
and Privacy- DEPA.
I think that is something
which has been- Yes.
I think MAYT has adopted it.
So, I think those guidelines
are supposed to be.
That's what someone who was
involved with that told me
that that will be
legally binding.
>> [inaudible].
>> No. Yes. Because
this privacy thing is like
a very recent thing which is kind
of brought to our attention
in some sense.
>> [inaudible] ?
>> I'll just come
to that next year.
So, now what we are
saying is that,
let us focus on the data layers.
We really need a well
defined data exchange layer.
It needs to be an open platform,
with open APIs and data models.
So, that instead of the siloed
it gets replaced by this,
what I'm showing is
a hourglass model.
At the neck of the hourglass
is the key, that is the city,
it's a little verbose
city data exchange
and Edge Analytic stack.
I'll tell you why Edge
Analytics is important shortly.
So, this data exchange stack,
what it does is,
it's an intermediary
between the producers of data,
which is all the sensors,
and the consumers of data,
all the applications.
The sensors could be
hardware sensors,
but it could also be
software sensors.
Other applications could do
further refinement of data
and produce alerts and
messages and so on.
Really this kind of
an open stack will
enable very complex
applications in the future.
Emergency response, we splice
together information from
multiple diverse sources
and connect with
multiple different ways of
connecting with citizens,
crowd monitoring,
accident detection
as well as prediction,
and preventing accidents.
So, that is what we really
need going forward.
To do a lot of these things
you need to integrate
analytics across video
and other sources.
If you see currently, video is
a complete separate
beast by itself.
Video is separate,
everything else is separate.
So, we really need to integrate,
as application developer you
need to be able to consume
a video stream as a less stream
coming from other sensors nearby.
Really this architecture is
something inspired by other,
this is what they do for other.
This is a course kernel
you identify
which enables a whole set
of ecosystems to
rebuilt around it.
If we do it right,
we can have portability
across vendors for devices,
as well as portability
across cities.
Application development
Bangalore should
work in Sura, et cetera.
So, I think that
is what we should
be aiming for as a country,
not have all these cities
independently just
doing their own little
thing and then,
at least just let's see if
we can do it correctly;
the smart city solutions.
That is our hope. Yeah.
>> Is there [inaudible]
Or will it just be lost
after whatever happens?
>> That is a good
question. So, nothing
explicit has been
mentioned in the RFP.
At least I could notice, but
certain numbers are mentioned.
For example, for surveillance
related application,
we know that people
want to store it
for at least 30 days or
something I believe,
and the video data.
The other sensor data is really
not much I guess
compared to video.
Video is really
the beast in some sense.
They are saying that you
have the archive data to
do further analysis
and help and so on.
But it's not really
been quantified.
I think that that
is the next level
where when I say be able to say,
okay, you need
this much amount of
storage to store
these kinds of data.
So, for video, it is there,
because certain requirements
require you to
store so many days
worth of data but.
>> [inaudible]
>> See, I think for video from
a forensic perspective they
definitely want the raw data.
In fact, you should not
be touching the raw data.
It should be as it is.
But there could be lot of
other cameras which are not
really part of the surveillance
system you're just put them.
For those, I guess
it's up to the how
you implement those.
I mean, do you really care
for this raw data coming
in where nothing
is happening like
a waste monitoring site.
You have a camera, you
just want to know if
someone is actually,
if people have showed up
to work or not maybe.
Maybe that's the alert you want,
so the raw data may not
be that useful there.
So, I think that is also
open in some sense.
>> Actually users forget to
store the use [inaudible]
>> So, that is really why
the Edge Analytics comes in.
In fact, from maybe,
I'll just say why we need
Edge Analytics is essentially
for what you pointed out.
The amount of video data is
just too much to
stream to the cloud.
Data has been locally
stored locally consumed.
>> Localized or local data?
>> Local is what? So, local
could be a word, maybe locality,
again it depends on the kind of
investment a city it
is able to put in.
I feel that it should be local at
a level of a ward of a locality
at a campus or some such thing.
Then that's what I'll kind of
discuss in the next few slides.
So that you don't
really ship this huge amounts
of data all over the place,
it just consume there,
and then that's why you need the
Edge Analytics also
running there.
It's only the alert
that are transient.
So, this data exchange
layer needs to have,
what are the attributes for this.
We need to have
very strong security,
handle heterogeneous data
across video,
and other IoT data.
These are the key functionality
of supporting exchange
of data between various
applications and devices.
Be a repository of data models,
because just raw data by
itself is not useful.
What is the metadata
about the data,
and that is something
else we insisted on
that every source of
data comes with
metadata information so
that you know what it means,
support low-latency,
have APIs, and SDKs.
Because of the need for
a local just for video,
if it is not video, probably
Edge Analytics might not be
that useful but maybe other
than for latency reasons.
But definitely, video requires
I think Fog/Edge Analytics.
Now, what was missing here,
we would like to also add
these three requirements that,
they should be strong
protections for privacy.
Say if someone is,
you should know as a citizen with
all cameras or whatever
video feeds you appear in,
I mean that would
be nice to know.
Then you need to have
a marketplace to be able
to buy and sell data,
and of course support the
AI type applications.
I'll kind of briefly mention
what I mean by that.
>> [inaudible] There
is no privacy anymore.
You are telling me I have
the right information.
>> Correct. Yeah. At
least be able to know.
You see because if we
take that forward.
Suppose cameras support but,
maybe you lack the data
in which you appear
or what you own.
That is unlocked
only based on, yeah,
>> Sorry. [inaudible]
. Is data privacy.
Supposed to deliver
it in index form,
which is what's
taking into account
the fact that GDPR in one end
is extremely strict and in
the US we have control.
Are they supposed to
be in [inaudible]
and that protection
on top of that,
there is going to be a law.
That's the end of my question.
>> Just additional information.
These cases where in Seattle
a system was abused by asking for
so much information by
the city authority to
satisfy those requests.
Then there's the issue
I think money products
where if you have access
to excessive data,
you are building a cost on
someone to deliver it to you.
So, is there any thinking
of how we will manage
excess and sustainability
of cost for?
>> I think those are
all opportunities
for startups to offer
services along those lengths.
That's what I think.
So for example,
Analytics-as-a-Service,
Annotation-as-a-Service,
all these are
interesting opportunities
to think of coming up
with solutions for those.
That's where these kinds of
data stacks which
are very open will
support those kinds of new kinds
of services to come up.
So, this is the stack,
basically what we're saying,
and it's not very
different from what any of
these IoT type stacks look like,
except there are
a few things out here.
Of course, you have
the brokers for
streaming messages
and alerts and so on,
which is an archive,
being able to access
these archived versions
of these messages.
Also, support for
real-time messaging,
but the video and audio,
the media brokers
and databases are
also part of the stack
so that you access this.
Basically, a directory of
data resources out here which is
a catalog which has
all the meta information.
Can I give you an example of
how that might look like,
support for certain
contexts because if you
want to really interpret
the data coming in,
you need to know
what is the context,
so that you can do
your inferences and so on.
So, that is what I
meant by AI support.
A specific example, I'll
just talk about the spaces.
Then, which is also very
important in the context
of video and Edge
Analytics is that you
need to be able to
support running of analytics and
not this support to run
analytics at the Fog
and the Edge layer.
Then as a framework
for authentication,
authorization, provisioning
et cetera, as part of this.
So this is basically the stack
and we want to- and all
this is exposed as APIs,
and each of them
runs as services or
microservices in some sense
from an implementation
perspective.
So if you look at from
a deployment option
you have the stack at the center,
and currently what will
probably happen is
that you already
might have applications running.
Waste Management, this
is an application
someone has developed et cetera.
So, with Adapters you put
data into the stack and
the command and Control
Center will pull data off
the stack in some sense
and also communicate
through this.
So, this is how probably
the immediate future
with legacy or ongoing
applications things will work out.
But maybe going forward
you cannot decouple
the data producing portion
from the data
consumption portion.
Even the data producing
person is just
done by a bunch of companies,
consuming is done by some
other kind bunch of companies,
and all of them work through
the Data Exchange Stack
in some sense.
So, what you can see from
the Command and Control Center is
not just the data but also
the health of the devices and
health of all the things
producing the data.
That is essentially
the management systems VMS,
Element Management System,
Network Management System.
They also report the health of
all these different things
to the Command and
Control Center.
Okay. When we think
in terms of that is kind
of a software perspective,
when you look at
the hardware perspective
what you will have is
a collection of gateways or
IoT gateways which are out
there publicly deployed,
but possibly on street poles,
because those are
something which are
all over the city they
have access to power.
So you have these
street poles where
each street pole has
this IoT gateway with a bunch of
locally wired connected sensors
and actuators and
perhaps also ingesting
data from nearby
sensors wirelessly.
All these street poles
are connected through
a WAN to the local
Micro Data Center.
So this could be at
the level of a campus
or a ward or locality.
This Micro Data Center actually
has the WAN terminator,
network switches and then compute
and storage services for it.
So this becomes the what
is called the Fog load,
some people call it the fog,
they have different
terminologies.
But this is the Micro
Data Center sitting
there serving a
locality out here.
So we expect this
to be the hardware realization
of the smart city solutions.
Anyway if you do it that way you
can do it in a modular fashion,
each locality gets lit up
in some sense or IoTified.
Then you have all these
Micro Data Centers
which are then managed
or visible as in a unified way
through Integrated Command
and Control Centers.
So this way you slowly
lighter different portions
of the city on
a step-by-step basis.
The software itself you
would want to of course
make it run in
a distributed fashion.
So, what here I'm showing
is that the core,
the API gateways and
the authentication et cetra is in
some sense unified
and centralized.
But the stack itself the brokers
et cetera are run in
a distributed fashion
each in the local
Micro Data Center.
So that way the whole thing
is actually distributed, okay.
So, there are
a few concepts which
we want to bring out here which
are I think interesting
and maybe some of them
are new in some sense.
So one is of course
a Registry of Data Sources.
Now this is something
which OCF is also there
multiple approaches
to our efforts to
try to come up with a schema,
a standard framework for
capturing the metadata.
So we will look at what OCF did,
and I were proposing
something along those lines.
Where any IoT source or
any data source has a schema
which has four pieces
of information.
There's some static information,
there is some schema
about the observation data
which comes in schema with
the control data which
goes to the device and
then schema for
the configuration data.
As an example out here
one of the elements
is the output of lux sensor
which is of type number which is
measuring the LED output
intensity, units of lux.
It has what we're also
seeing is that there is
an access modifier to
control the privacy
setting out here.
So you have private data,
you have protected data,
you have public data.
Private data is only accessible
to the owner of the data,
whereas protected is data
which is available to
someone who is authorized,
and public is open to
available to everyone.
Now, this kind of schema
that the idea is that
any data source when
it gets registered
in the system also has
to put in a schema
which tells you about the format
of the data coming in.
Then the system can
validate the pieces
of actual data which come
in against the schema
that is what is shown out
here on the right side.
So, as an example if
you take a street light
which through of schema
which is a proposal
schema which we
have experimenting with in
our reference implementation,
which gives you
some meta information,
this is a static portion.
Where is the street light
located? Who owns it?
How do you access the data
from the street light which
is what does the
subscription endpoint?
What is the API endpoint
for getting archival data?
Then the data from
the street light
itself what are
the different pieces of data
which come in essentially when is
like this a sampling instead.
Which is the temperature of
the casing,
the power consumption,
the ambient lux et cetera,
and then some meta information
describing each of those.
So, this is the
control inflammation
that is how do you go and change
the brightness level for
example of the street light.
So, the actual data from
the street light will of course
be decent type documents,
keyword values which
are adhering to
that particular schema out there.
So, that is the
first thing is that
every piece of data has to have
this data model
which is uploaded.
Second is video itself, right?
So now with video,
we would like to also treat
video as an IoT element.
What does it really mean for
video to be an IoT element?
Well, we need to have some
metadata about the video,
and metadata on the semantic
content of the video
not just the frame rate
and resolution and so on.
But what is inside these?
Some description that we had
this lux sensor and
the units are lux.
Is there some other similar
information we can put
maybe over the semantic content
or some associated inflammation.
I'll give you a simple example.
So, for example if I look
out here someone go do
an analytics on
this video and give out
this meta data stream
which is associated
with the video stream.
Which tells me are there
any Autos in this video sequence?
How many diesel vehicles
are there? Et cetra.
The thing is these kinds
of analytics then
help the consumer to
work off the analytics
data and not worry
about the raw data anymore
or the encoded video stream.
Now you're working on a derived
information as you go forward.
This will really enable
complex applications to be
built where you build on
this kind of analytics.
It'll also allow analytics
service providers who develop
very specific analytics and offer
them as analytic stream.
So, the formatting is a
little messed up here.
So for example, a
simple use cases,
let us say you have a mobile
video source like a drone,
and the drone is giving out
the encoded video
stream but you'd
like to know what are
the Geo-location,
as a time series,
so that that is extra meta
information because you
had that maybe Geo-location
maybe the posts of the drone,
you can do better much more
interesting inferences
with the video stream.
So, it is just a simple schema
to describe that
very similar to the schema
of the street light.
Here I'm just looking
at the data portion
of the schema which is telling me
that this is the timestamp
of the metadata.
You need to be able to refer
into the video stream,
what portion of the video stream
is this piece of
Meta Data actually matching to?
Start an end pointer
of the video?
Then what is actual data coming?
Is just the latitude longitude
in this particular example saying
that this portion of
the video frame this
is the Geo-location.
So you have now a stream of,
let's have this picture
again it tells you you have
the video stream which is
going flowing out here.
You have this Meta Data
corresponding to
the video stream which is
flowing on the side of tier.
So for example this piece of
this Meta-Data Stream
each metadata packet
actually is referring to
some portion of the video and
then contain some information
about that video stream.
So, this is one thing. So, have
this Meta-Data stream which
is also in the catalog.
So, any consumer will
know okay what is
this derived
information available
so you can build some new
applications on top of it.
Secondly if you want
to subscribe to
the video stream itself
you need to have a way
of just like you
would subscribe to
IoT Data Stream you
need to be able to
subscribe to Video Streams.
So you need to have
steaming servers,
be able to access
archive streams et cetera,
and the corresponding metadata
which comes in out here.
So, one of the things
is a lot of the
video especially for
the surveillance
camera is awfully
locals push
spatio-temporal relevance.
No one else outset
really cares about it.
So, I'm just going to
highlight here problem,
we are thinking about
is how do you create
this localized efficient
video distribution system
for the local region.
So, this I think is where
you have load balancing,
you have caching of
these brokers etc done.
For example, you're stuck
in a traffic junction,
or you're stuck in the
road and you want to know
what is happening ahead.
You're just curious.
With your city app, you're
able to subscribe to
a video camera which is
just ahead and you'll see,
okay this is why there
is a problem there.
You're just curious to know.
This kind of a local consumption
of video from a local source
to be able to support
these things.
Also, be able to kind of adapt
the QOS of the local network.
For example, if I have
some incidents happening
in a local region,
you probably won't allocate
more bandwidth to the cameras
around that region.
Maybe you want to
track a crowd as
it's going past, right?
So, adaptive QOS
for those things.
So these are some of the,
I would say interesting
RND problems.
I'm not saying this
will be part of
the stack which we're
doing but these are
some interesting problems which
are worth looking at
as we go forward.
The thing with the
video is that you want
to get and consume the video,
and analyze the video locally.
Right now, of
course, you do it at
the Fog layer because those
a Standard Compute Servers,
but I guess with
technologies which you guys
are developing MSR you can also
push that to the Edges out
here on the IoT gateways.
Now the thing is
that this collective
of the Micro Data Center,
and this IoT gateway in
some sense forms cloud.
I call it the street cloud.
So, you have to come-
and street cloud
has this heterogeneous
compute two sources.
Little computes in
the IoT gateways and
more compute in the
compute servers.
So, basically you want
to locally terminate the video
both for privacy and bandwidth,
and you want to
run this analytics
out here in the street cloud.
So, how do you do that?
What is the programming model
to allow you to develop
applications like this,
in a general way and what kind
of runtime is required
to support that?
So, this is something
again I think is
an interesting systems problem
to look at as you go forward.
As an example, we have
been looking at how you
could take advantage and do
this Distributed Video Analytics.
So, where you have
a camera and you have
some compute to the poll
right next to the camera,
and then you have
more heavier duty
compute out in
the Micro Data Center.
So here what we have
explored is how you can do
this tracking locally and
the object detection out
in the Micro Data Center.
So, this is some work
we did last year,
where you have multiple cameras
and then you have
an object detector running
the Micro Data Center,
and the D-frames are
the frames on which you
do the object detection
in the data center,
whereas the D-frames are done
locally next to the camera
to do the tracking.
So, the detector
of course runs is
a much heavier duty detector
running on one of
these neural nets and
locally you do
the tracking et cetera.
So, there is some benefit
to doing this,
we reported last year.
But, I think more
interesting question is how
do you when you
write this because
it's always a moving target,
the amount of compute
you have every year is
improving even in the Edge Node
you can do more and more compute.
So, you can't hard partition
your thing saying that,
"What you couldn't do today maybe
two years from now you can do
easily in the Edge compute."
So, how do we write
these applications and break
it so that these pieces are
able to move around easily
and collectively they
do the job you want to?
So that I think is also
very interesting problem.
So, there is this,
the third concept which
we kind of want to
articulate out here is
concept of space as an asset.
Space regions, and this is
something which actually
Intel has brought
to our attention.
OTR who are also part
of our collaborators.
So, this particular
conference room
is the space region which will
be there in the database.
Because if you have sensors out
there for example
the smoke detectors,
you should be able to pin it to
this particular space region
which means this space region
needs to have a entity,
a presence in your database
with a specific ID so
that you can tie to that.
It can't just be the Geolocation,
because the Geolocation really
and not work well inside.
So that is a concept where
you have spaces
articulated as assets.
The thing is that for example,
this space if you take,
this is the map
just outside around
this vicinity where you have
your Microsoft building,
you have ITC gardenia, et cetera.
So I've just marked out
three space region.
So there is this SR1 which
is this piece of road,
SR2 is your Microsoft building,
SR3 is this another
building out here.
These regions have to
be captured somehow.
Of course, in the database
you will have
SR1 as a region which
has a unique ID,
it's described by
the street segment
owned by the city of Bangalore,
administered by BBMP et cetera.
Similarly, you have associated
information for every regions,
but more importantly you have
a structure which connects
these space regions together.
Saying that, SR1 is adjacent
to SR2, SR3, et cetera,
and SR1 is part of this bigger
Space Region called road,
RajaRamMohanRoad and so on.
Now, why is this interesting?
Because you can use
this structure to build
your application.
For example, suppose
there is an incident
which happens in this SR1
which is the road segment
just in front of you.
Who are the people who need
to be informed about that?
So, what I want to just
build a general application
without customizingly doing
it for this particular.
So, where then what you would do
is you take that you
look at the network
in this graph structure
and traverse that
and figure out what
all the affected people who
get notified about that accident.
So, this is the context
what I meant by saying
supporting AI services,
is that you capture the context.
This context is most likely
in the form of a graph.
It's not just be contexts of
the space region it could also be
context which is related
to this organizational
structures.
So the're many things out
here which are useful,
it's probably should be captured.
So, I think that the challenge
here is to populate
the database with such kind
of information in
a maybe automated way perhaps
a semi-automated way.
So that you have a rich database
which you can now
start using to do more and more
interesting automated
DI type applications.
So, but at a minimum at
least what we are
saying is let us
start with the space
regions and make
that available as a database.
This link should be able
to automatically create analyzing
the shape files and so on.
Finally, the security,
privacy, and manageability.
Regarding privacy, I will
just briefly mention that,
there is work which is
going on in India Stack
as part of privacy,
supporting privacy.
They have something
called a Consent
layer which they're proposing.
So, one can look at that and
see how we can adopt it.
But the idea is that,
there is a clear
ownership of data,
who owns data, and
the data can only
be used with the permission
of the owner of the data.
So that is basically what we want
to be able to support out there.
Also, it will be good
to be able to track.
If I share data with you,
you don't share it with someone
else without my knowledge.
So you need to also have
a mechanism for doing that.
So I think those all
can be done now with
this modern encryption and
Public key, PK technologies.
So, what we have done is
these are all concepts at
various levels of maturity.
Some of it is actually
work in progress,
and we have actually
been working on
implementing some of
these. Yes, go ahead.
>> [inaudible]
>> Yeah. So,
basically every device
in the system needs to,
"in some sense," have similar
to our biomedical identification.
Every device needs to have
an identification which
is somehow tied to some root
of trust of some kind.
I think some of these things
the enterprise level people
have already solutions for that.
The question is are they-
like you have these TPMs,
you have this Trust
Zones et cetera.
>> [inaudible] from the device.
The mechanism [inaudible] ?
>> The access to the data is,
you have to get
access to the data.
So, there's the owner
of the data.
In the case, it
could be the city.
So, if you want to
access those streams,
you need to have a relationship
with the city to get
access to the data.
Now, if you do some bad things in
the data, that could happen,
but there is some very clear,
shall we say, audit trail.
As you have taken the data,
it's recorded somewhere.
>> I provide some [inaudible]
>> Right.
Yeah. I guess, yeah,
it's possible.
I don't know. I mean,
security is a big topic.
There could be ways of
hacking around the system.
But the thing is that at least
the point is there is
an end-to-end encryption
with also strong identification
of devices and humans, right?
So, there's identity
management system in place,
and the data is only
given to authorized
people essentially.
The owner of the data
authorizes the use of the data.
So, that is the kind of
framework we can put in.
>> Sometimes [inaudible]
security and privacy.
Do you see that
those [inaudible].
>> See, right now,
it is at a very high level
if you remember,
they will say using slot files
and online certificates,
that is the level.
So, that is where
the next level of
detail as to what it should
be in more precise terms.
>> This is the precise, I mean,
this is an implementation
detail, right?
What do I care about whether it's
using one certificate,
another certificate.
I want to know what my
end-to-end guarantees,
and then work backwards and
figure out what cryptographic
protocols are needed.
>> Right.
>> [inaudible] has
started themes.
>> You're right. The certificates
are one way of implementing
security. I agree with you.
So, what we are
actually doing is that,
at a high level, you want
encrypted communication.
That is a high level requirement.
But how do you achieve
that encrypted
communication, right?
So, what we want to actually
propose now, essentially,
what we are doing is,
I'll just come to that,
but there the consortium we are
making where we're coming up
with these more
detailed specification.
Some of it on the security side
is on the implementation,
probably, it is at the flavor
of implementation.
Use this, yeah, so
that's what it is, yes.
So, there's a lot of POC work,
which we are doing with some
of these devices you're making.
This a concept smart pole,
which we are made,
which can have
these smart street light,
which is on this pole,
and there is a gateway out here,
which has, of course, a
Raspberry Pi on that.
Then, we have a network
of these poles,
and this is just an
example application
where very toy application,
where you could use video data,
have an antiques runoff
the video data,
and then do something to
manage your street lights.
So, where this heterogeneous
things through a same platform
allows you to do that stuff.
So, what we have here is a
pole with a camera pointing.
>> How much power will
be consumed if you had
a Raspberry PI
[inaudible] every device?
>> I don't think
the Raspberry Pi is
consumes that much power because
the street lights themselves are
about 30 watts to 90 watts.
Raspberry Pi will be a few watts.
So, it's not going to be much.
The cameras are also quite,
they can consume
quite a bit of power
compared to that
because cameras are
pretty much in a nice box
with the optics, and so on.
>> So, it's a very
[inaudible] yeah.
It's a Chicago array of things.
She was trying to deploy
a significant set of sensors,
very strategically
packaged around the city.
The concept was to put thousands
of these, 10 thousands of these.
They were funded for that.
Five years later, it turns out,
there are about a 150 nodes,
and the deployment
cost in Chicago,
which is a different situation is
about three to $5,000 per pole.
So, what's been
the experience doing
all base power source
[inaudible].
>> I think there's not much
experience frankly speaking.
So, in fact, this would probably
related cannot go ahead
and see is it even
worth putting these Computes
every pole everywhere.
I think some of that we have
to learn as you go forward.
So, we are not there.
Yeah, I agree with you, yeah.
In fact, we have
had some discussion
with the idea of things people,
and so on, and that was,
we wanted to use that,
but then we realized
it's too expensive for
us what they have right now.
So, yeah. So anyway,
this particular you've
probably seen this video,
so I'll just move on.
All this is saying, it's
just so people detector,
which turns on the street lights,
so it's only simple thing.
We are actually doing this,
setting this test bed
in Electronic City.
They're being very
willing to work with us,
so there is
a fiber loop out here.
This Infosys Avenue,
Wipro Avenue,
and this other road,
and the stars are
the junctions where
there's some cameras,
which had been set
up, and all this data
is going into
a Micro Data Center,
which is set up in their office.
So, like that, there
are two other rings.
So, there're these three rings,
which had been set up now,
and all the data is coming in,
and this reference stack,
which we are developing
can be put out there,
and we can develop
the stack as we go along with
actual data coming in
from these sources.
Of course, they are interested
in traffic management,
so we wanted to see if we
can help them with that.
Hopefully, with
this kind of activity,
we can have a solid stack,
which is tested out and
made available to people.
>> So, portal data
is collected here?
>> Basically, right now,
you see in Electronic City,
they have these cameras out here,
then they have a solid
waste management system,
and they're trying hard to set up
a smart street life
management system,
and parking is something
which they're concerned with.
Parking management is
something they want to do.
>> Does that mean
infrared sensors out there?
>> Right now, they're
doing infrared sensors,
these are just standard cameras,
but we'll put one or
two thermal images also
as an experiment in
this test bed to see what
we can do with this, yeah.
This is the network,
there are optical fiber loop,
which is based on GIPON,
Gigabit Passive Optical Network.
Each of the poles in
Electronic City has
this connectivity to the spawn.
There is a LoRa Network
also to pick up data
from some of the sensors
and LoRa based sensors.
So, they are also very
interested in water management.
So, smart water management is
another use case for them.
So, we are also looking at how
to create API interface to
the network itself
so that some of
the things I mentioned
about adaptive QS,
and so on, can be
experimented as part of this.
So, the application can go
and change the network city.
Of course, going forward,
these kinds of
interfaces in the street
become interesting to
support autonomous vehicles,
so connected autonomous vehicles.
So, those where you
can have these poles
have beacons and embedded
sensors, radars, et cetera.
This again, where Edge Compute
becomes very interesting
for low latency
controlled everything.
This is a different applications,
it's not video analytics
from a privacy perspective.
Bandwidth reduction is more
from a latency perspective.
Again, this is I think
the open problem challenge of
how do you do this reliable
real-time control,
especially for mobile things
as things are moving around.
This is also in sync
with the 5G activity.
So, this kind of a setup is also
planning to use to create
a 5G test bed for that.
So, I'm going to talk
about different things.
Some of it to more research,
and some of it more mundane,
but the thing is that for
the city stack, the data stack,
the way we are going about
it now is we are forming
a consortium of
academia industry consortium
with some companies like Intel,
Dell, VMware, Tejas,
Bosch, Cisco.
These are all interested to
be part of this consortium.
So, now we're working
together to develop
the more detailed specification
of this particular data layer.
I've also left others out here.
So hopefully, they'll interested,
so Microsoft to also
participate in this,
and other companies
as we go forward.
The idea is that stack,
which we are seeing
the data layer stack
is articulated out,
a reference implementation is
created and made available.
It should be open
reference implementation,
completely open-source
technology.
Hopefully, that gets tested
out in Electronic City.
So, it's a solid stack,
and hopefully, that can become
the kernel for all smart
city implementations
as we go forward in India.
So, that is the aspiration.
So, just to summarize,
that data layer is what we are
focusing on as part of
the smart city solutions,
because that's
key foundational layer,
and it needs to be
open with SDKs,
APIs, and so on,
and the reference implementation
will be open-source
and made available,
and it should be
looking at the future,
enabling future
applications in AI,
and distributed computing,
and things like that.
It can't be done by one entity,
and really needs a consortium.
A lot of these
problems, probably,
US have also figured out,
but I think with companies,
this is where
the academia comes in it.
It can be a neutral entity
which can help get
this kind of activity going.
This would probably be
something unique in India,
and this happens
routinely in the West,
but this will be
something interesting
if you can do it in India.
So, with that, I would like to
thank really good team
we have in the Robert
Bosch Center at IISC,
and also these members of
the India Stack Consortium,
which is evolving, and I hope
that some of you can also
participate in that.
So, thank you for the attitude.